kratom queen so Brendan Amanda from
Sacramento and I have a debate clip for
you guys been spending a lot of time in
quarantine a lot of time at home
watching TV and it reminds me of those
days when I was a kid from school just
so I could stay home and watch The Price
is Right so who do you guys think is the
better host is it drew Carey or that og
Bob Barker let me know what you guys
think debated I want to hear your
thoughts love you guys
Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz buzz we had a
you know to score and four years ago we
had a dog in our neighborhood they
called it Bob Barker because it was
always real live in antifreeze and a
freeze boom and he stopped barking oh
yeah shut down he shut it down Bob bark
is the real gangster [ __ ] both these
boys I would hurry up home and watch a
Jerry Springer really
oh dude a spring or was on about 3 p.m.
get them school at 2:00 I brush on watch
Jerry Springer Wow
why for the violence you think that's
probably that's early UFC really it
really was you know I love Jerry
Springer man as much what I thought it
was real oh oh nothing like it man yeah
and then he always left you with a good
like yeah final thought Jerry's final
thought thinking was bouncer Steve
Jerry's final thought dude I saw him at
the beach one time in San Diego was bad
so I'm walking with his daughter or some
meaty meaty girl oh I forgot to tell you
when I was in Laguna I'm real meat stick
something you'd have thrown on the grill
yeah when I was in Laguna I saw your boy
the pastor you did yeah our Lance yeah
it's your boy it was my boy but you
introduced me to him yeah great guy but
remember I was joking around calm the
[ __ ]
yeah you shouldn't have done it talk to
him
yeah yeah good-looking dude man Carl
yeah I mean he's okay I'm he's handsome
but I'm I wouldn't say hey dude he's
good-looking God but I'm not gonna say
it off him
a little conversation oh yeah Carl's
awesome man I love Carl dude yeah super
nice yeah they got a tiger game a high
five pastor named Judah was really good
at what he faced yeah I know judo he do
yep I don't do that every surgeon here
they're in he's in Seattle I think or
like Portland right Church home is the
church that they do here that's on
Wednesday nights on Wilshire but I think
it hasn't been open because of Tobit the
disease you know you know where churches
at Chabot I have Jesus Christ never
leaves you if you get over there man
mm-hmm don't know you man I had time for
that chain they'll think you come
straight out the Bible sir out of Egypt
bro
you wear that neck piece I'll be like
dang this guy's write a chapter six here
they'll love you i tiger give a carl in
to high five guys [ __ ] give him some
fist no I was like God dude no and I
said you know hopefully you don't think
they said if he's like not me guys are
great
oh good I said thanks dude please don't
tell the big man upstairs yeah he's a
cool guy man I love Carl yeah I do I
like both him and Judith yeah but uh hey
listen with Drew Carey to me it's a
little bit of a cop-out I get he's
making [ __ ] Bank but doing that job
everyday kind of selling your soul to
the devil man cuz he was a gangster
remember he did whose line is it anyway
he's a big comic kiddush his show that
was basically you know drew Carey show
he was killing it when you do this you
just selling your soul man yeah like no
one's watching really anymore oh come on
down wait baby watch people are watching
I used to get Nick look at the rating
stock ain't nobody watched that [ __ ]
no look I used to get sick just to stay
home and watch it what come on at 10:00
a.m. and that came on it meant that you
were skipping school yeah you were
living life mom was at work or doing
some [ __ ] dead-end job that she'd
scored and you
had a chance at millions of dollars even
though you really didn't know and see
Drew Carey all the time sorry mom mom I
would fake like I was sick in my mom
would drop me off at my grandma's yeah
and then I'll just watch TV I watch
SportsCenter all day but then flip back
the [ __ ] price is right you know yeah
I'm more sinners and [ __ ] Price is
Right and I just couldn't wait for that
Jerry Springer to hit that was America
bro
no [ __ ] women 2020 yeah I know what the
fight is look at us right now I don't
know you look like [ __ ] good day son I
do declare dude any other different
types of that like if you would do that
it just meant like gotta go you know no
but if you did that a minute I'm gonna
be here for a while and if you did this
to me that means got a little sugar I'm
at home sex talk about Steve that's real
sugar I'm real that's not that
bipartisanship
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]